see you do want to be a dreamer but you
don't want to stop there
isn't it funny you want people tell you
have big dreams but that hey don't be a
dreamer yeah you do want to have big
dreams but being just a dreamer what
that means is is that you don't do
anything you just talk about stuff all
the time
like if your daughter comes home and
she's dating a guy and she says Oh
daddy's a dreamer you go oh crap they're
gonna live in the basement right that's
what you think of when you think a
dreamer right so dreams are a big deal
you need to have a dream but if you stop
there then you're just a dreamer dreams
you need to blow the clouds off the
dreams and let them become visions and
visions with work clothes on or called
goals and then you start getting very
specific and you ask yourself what must
be true for us to be able to do that for
me to be in that career for me to lose
30 pounds for my marriage to be better
from a spiritual walk to be different my
relationship with God to be stronger
what has to be true that's not true now
what has to change what books do I need
to read classes do I need to take
different people do I need to associate
with if you've got a drinking problem
and you continue to run around with your
drinking buddies you're gonna have a
drinking problem something needs to
change you become who you hang around
with you talk like them you read the
same books they do you watch the same
movies they do and you binge watch the
same series on Netflix that they do but
if you start running around with a bunch
of people who are unbelievably generous
they are careful with their money so
that they can be unbelievably generous
they get out of debt and stay out of
that which makes them in our culture
weird and you start running around with
people that are doing that you're much
more likely to do it that's why we put
you in accountability groups in
Financial Peace University it's called
positive peer pressure it helps behavior
modification it's basic stuff y'all
that's how it works
you become who you hang around with you
know this because you don't let your
children run around with people who are
misbehaving if little Johnny down the
street smoking weed you don't want your
little kid running around with a little
Johnny because your kid will be a weed
head you know you know this you know
that they're gonna become who they hang
around with you ever send your kids off
when they're eight years old to play at
the neighbors and they come back using
words we don't use it our house it was
not accidental
that means that kid or those parents are
using those words at that house what do
you mean you're dropping the f-bomb at
eight years old in my house or you want
to live I mean I can make another one
just like you I'll take you out you know
you're not gonna do that here this I
mean you know have you ever had that
experience with your kids that's because
of who they were running around with
it's simple you're gonna become who you
hang around with do you know your income
will be approximately within ten to
fifteen percent of the average of your
closest ten friends over a 10-year
period of time if you run around with
people that say the little man can't get
ahead you're running around with losers
if you run around with people to say
well you know people like us can't win I
had a friend of mine this very wealthy
and he grew up in the hood that's what
he calls it he said you know Dave
getting out of the hood was a lot easier
than getting the hood out of me the
tapes that are played from your
childhood the tapes that are played from
the people that supposedly do love you
but that are misguided in your head that
say things like people like us can't get
ahead don't you understand but your
stand that people from the south are all
treated like they're ignorant and live
in double wides
and walk around with no shoes buy a
bunch of you Yankees don't you
understand that
people in the South think all you people
in New York are rude and I'm actually
friends with all of you so I'm okay I
actually love New Yorkers because they
do speak their mind and they get
straight to the point
and they never say bless your heart
which in the south can mean anything you
know something you become who you hang
around with y'all gettin this down you
become who you mean if you believe if
all you hang around with are people that
talk politics from your side of the
aisle it's the only talking point you
know and you've not had an original
thought in years
and develop your critical thinking
skills and get past the idea that Barack
Obama or Donald Trump are the savior
because neither one are and by the way
none of them I've ever sent me any money
everything good that's happened in my
life none of it came out of Washington
DC none of it I mean what are you who
you running around with who you got your
runaround people waiting on Washington
to fix their life are you running around
with people that say education is a bad
idea are you running around with people
to say oh yeah student loan debt no
matter what you pay for it is worth it
are you running around with people that
fill in the blank you're gonna become
just like them a dream does not become a
reality through magic Colin Powell said
it takes sweat determination and hard
work